year was a few weeks ago and highly
acclaimed Dragon Ball Dokken and legends
artist fenyo was living his life as he
usually did posting personal fan art of
Dragon Ball on his feed like usual but
then on that fateful day the unthinkable
happened some Rando sent feno a DM on
Instagram commanding fenyo to draw
Android 18 in a bikini this DM
inexplicably rewired fenyo's brain
chemistry because he posted a screenshot
of the DM and wrote a message to the
effect of I've just realized that having
a personal Instagram means I'm allowed
to post whatever I want before all of
this happened his entire page was a
Bastion of cute Dragon Ball fan art
mashups of characters what ifs General
fanart the whole shebang but after this
fateful day everything changed we got
Saucy kefla Android 21 Chichi a Bulma
multiple of the Dells the list now goes
on endlessly it's literally all he posts
now